what's up everybody jared again
today we're talking about anime's most
powerful pipsqueak
sorry about that edward now fullmetal
alchemist brotherhood has
all the trappings of an instant classic
high concept science fiction
check awesome fight scenes definitely
strong philosophical core well that's
why we're here
throughout edward and alfons's journey
to restore their bodies the two are
confronted with various discourses on
the efficacy and application of science
or in their case
alchemy sure it's through alchemy that
they hope to recover their bodies but
they also see it used for some pretty
awful things
[Music]
so what is brotherhood saying about
science and the way it's applied to this
world
and how does faith fit into this
discussion well let's find out
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of full metal alchemist
brotherhood
and of course spoilers ahead but first a
quick primer
fullmetal alchemist brotherhood is set
in a mestress a country reminiscent of
pre-world war ii europe whose defining
feature is the success
of alchemy or the manipulation and
altering of matter using natural energy
alchemy is essentially treated as a
science one that combines chemistry and
biology with its own unique laws and
principles
alchemy's most important law the law of
equivalent exchange
or you know the law that means if you
get the right materials and draw a
circle
you can do this the show establishes a
push and pull dynamic between science
and faith
almost immediately in episode 3 ed and
al
travel to the desert town of lyor to
investigate father cornello
a holy figure who has gained control of
the people by
awliying them with miracles and
indoctrinating them in the faith of
leoism
the second they arrive though the
brothers make their views abundantly
clear to the faithful
[Music]
and their skepticism toward the divine
is justified
as it turns out cornello's miracles are
just cleverly veiled
applications of alchemy that he uses to
attract followers willing to
die for him eden al exposed cornello as
a fraud and liberate the people of lyor
from his ideological tyranny
so science rules faith drools right well
not so fast
in the following episode the brothers
are sent to study under the sewing life
alchemist
show tucker tucker was the first
alchemist to successfully create a
talking chimera and tries to repeat his
success
in order to retain his state alchemist
certification the rx fascination
quickly turns to horror and in one of
the biggest gut punches in anime history
we see this
yeah that's right tucker actually used
his family dog
and his own daughter as components to
create his chimera
but far from feeling remorse tucker
claims he was only doing what science
demands
in the face of such an atrocity science
no longer
seems so innocent does it so where does
this conflict between science and faith
lead us
tucker the amoral alchemist in search of
scientific knowledge at any cost
largely sets the tone for the rest of
the show over its 64 episodes
brotherhood forces us to question the
value of single-mindedly clinging to
science and the consequences of reducing
all knowledge to scientific terms
a mode of thought loosely known in the
real world as scientism
now i know what you're thinking jared
doubting science is what people in a
cult do
but just humory when philosophers
critique scientism they're not saying
that science is a lie
what they're criticizing is how we put
scientific knowledge
above all other knowledge and how we try
to reduce other forms of knowledge into
it
according to philosopher paul fireauband
science is just one of
many competing explanatory frameworks
one which is neither as
rational nor consistent as it pretends
to be fire robin's favorite example is
copernicus whose heliocentric model of
the universe was actually rejected by
scientists of his day
to them aristotle's idea of celestial
spheres
offered a fuller explanation of why the
planets moved in the sky
while copernicus's model could correctly
calculate the movement of the planets
it couldn't explain why they moved as
they did until newton's theory on
gravity was published over a century
later
science in this case wasn't interested
in the truth
so much as self-preservation like any
ideology fire robin worries that an
unquestioning acceptance of it
like with lior and lidoism can lead to
some potentially disastrous results
in his book against method and science
in a free society
firerobin asks is it not possible that
science as we know it today
or a search for the truth in the style
of traditional philosophy
will create a monster and monsters are
exactly what science creates in the
world of brotherhood
such as man-made chimeras that are
referred to as ungodly experiments
[Music]
this impersonal dehumanizing aspect of
alchemy is enshrined in the law of
equivalent exchange
which inherently reduces objects animals
and even people to their physical
components
the ulrich brothers entire journey
starts because the two believe they can
bring their mother back to life
by simply transmuting the basic
ingredients of a human being
this dehumanizing nature is furthered by
one of alchemy's most
sought-after creations the philosopher's
stone
when ed and al decode dr marco's notes
they realize the key ingredient to the
stone
is human
[Music]
the stone is the ultimate product of
alchemy allowing its users to ignore the
law of equivalent exchange
but even though the stone can restore
edenal's bodies
the two are reluctant if not just plain
unwilling to use the stone
in contrast the homunculi artificial
humans powered by philosopher stones
regurgitates scientismic philosophy
reducing the souls trapped within the
stones
to mere alchemic principles
[Music]
while ed and al both use the power of
the stones on one occasion each
they do so while respecting the autonomy
of those souls
[Music]
this distinguishes the brothers as moral
according to philosopher immanuel kant
who famously stated that you must treat
humanity whether in your own person or
in the person of any other
always at the same time as an end never
merely as a means for kant people are
never meant to be used or reduced to
calculations but rather
are always a goal in themselves but eden
al's problem with alchemy
is larger than its impersonal nature but
also
its subservience to the military alchemy
is so
under the control of the amestrian
government that there are actually
three state-appointed tenants of alchemy
the first of which is
literally obey the military
in fact state alchemists are generally
referred to as dogs of the military and
even
as human weapons
in his book science wars sociologist
stanley aranowitz argues that scientists
often view themselves as
vehicles facilitating the advancement of
learning and by application the progress
of mankind
yet scientist funding must come from
somewhere
and often it's from corporations or the
state
as such scientists don't really own
their discoveries and have
little say about their application
throughout the anime ed
constantly clashes with this
militarization of science by the state
and his own complicity with it as alex
armstrong succinctly puts it
thinking
we even see this military influence
distort the basic principles of science
when edinault reminisce about being
trained on a desert island as children
they come to the epiphany that alchemy
is all about understanding the natural
flow of
energy both deconstructing and
reconstructing it
[Music]
but this principle is later twisted in
the mouths of the military
in justifying destroying the whole
country and slaughtering its population
one general even goes so far as to
rephrase it as alchemic rebirth
[Applause]
as tools of the government alchemists
have become the very
instruments of the series chief
antagonist father who controls the
emestrian state
father desires nothing more than to
assume the mantle of god
a goal which he's used alchemy countless
military conflicts
and millions of innocent lives to
prepare for in fact a mestre's most
brutal
and heartless war the ishvalan war of
extermination was fought
just to further father's plan and it's
this war where the state alchemists made
their largest military impact
what's shocking about ishbal isn't just
the devastating force that alchemy
wrecked on it
but the scientific language used to
explain it even the good guys here can't
help but couch what's essentially
genocide
in these sterile scientific terms
[Music]
in fact this sanitizing nature of
scientific language is what escalated
the ishvalan war to new heights
as fury king bradley told the high
priest of ishvala when he offered
himself up in exchange for a ceasefire
the law of equivalent exchange
won't allow it
to stop
hell the fuhrer even considers his wife
to be nothing more than an expendable
pawn for his greater scheme
now if the title of fuhrer is raising
eyebrows among you
there's a good reason for that the
country of a mistress is reminiscent of
pre-world war ii germany
a militant nation expanding beyond its
borders and a blond-haired blue-eyed
army whose uniforms look
a lot like that of the ss even the might
is right motivation behind nazi germany
bubbles to the surface in a mestress
as general raven invokes social
darwinism to justify
mass extermination
tonight
and if that's not enough to convince you
then you only have to compare a mestre's
human experiments
to that of auschwitz's lead doctor
joseph mengele
whether it's raising babies in
underground laboratories
stitching together people and animals or
ripping
souls from bodies it's hard to say that
a mistress lacks the same wanton cruelty
and morbid scientific curiosity that
defined mengele's operations
menkala established a kindergarten at
auschwitz for his younger experiments
allegedly stitching two gypsy girls
together
and if he could have gotten his hands on
a literal soul he
probably would have mutilated it oh yeah
did we mention that fire robin
actually fought as a lieutenant in world
war ii even earning an iron
cross in the process witnessing first
hand the scientific arguments made by a
dictatorship for war and genocide
it's no surprise that fire alban would
one day propose a separation between
science and state
with ultimate power resting in democracy
in his lecture how to defend society
from science
he argued there must be a formal
separation between state and science
just as there is now a formal separation
between state and church
scientists may be consulted on important
projects but the final judgment must be
left to the democratically elected
consulting bodies
so it's safe to say that fullmetal
alchemist presents a cautionary tale
about the blind adherence to science
but what does it say about faith well
throughout its 64-episode run
faith is often portrayed as another
explanatory model
another source of truth and power in
fact for a show populated almost
entirely by scientists
the characters make a number of appeals
to faith in the episode the miracle of
rush valley ed and al witness the
delivery of a baby
become awestruck and point out the
limitations of alchemy
dr marco the alchemist largely
responsible for the creation of the
philosopher's stone during the ishval
civil war
calls it fate that he met the ishvalan
scar before the two set out together to
challenge the government
similarly knox who worked as a doctor
during the war and was subsequently
estranged from his family
invokes god when they've returned to him
[Music]
now even bradley a homunculus
wonders if his own death at the hand of
star was providence
bradley who mercilessly killed these
fallen people during the war
was told that god would strike him down
one day
and it was the sun looking like a
crescent moon which together symbolized
god in alchemy that blinded him and
allowed scar to
strike the finishing glow so is that the
thematic takeaway of the show
science is bad faith is good so keep on
praying
well not quite see the problem with
scientism isn't that science is bad and
that non-science is good
fire robin isn't giving the middle
finger to vaccines and posting about
chemtrails on twitter
nope instead his main contention is that
science is just one of
many ideas that propel society and
should be treated thus
what fire robin opposes is any
unreflective veneration of any ideology
because it inhibits free thought as it
turns out the blind following of science
as the arbiter of truth is
just as harmful as the blind following
of faith as the arbiter of truth
whether it's father cornello and the
homunculi using the lidois to incite
violence against their enemies
or scar using his goddess vala to
justify his vengeance against the
alchemist
faith alone can be every bit just as
scary as science
characters grow in brotherhood when they
realize the limitations of adhering to
any one ideology
edward and alphonse for example begin to
question the foundations of western
alchemy which supposedly takes its
energy from the tectonic movements of
the earth's mantle
when father manages to cancel it out
it's their quest for an explanation
that leads them to science's eastern
equivalent alka history which uses life
energy from the planet
it's ultimately bridging the gap between
these two ideologies that allows our
heroes to eventually triumph the two
different sciences come together to make
a reverse transmutation circle that
saves the lives of all le mestras
perhaps no character embodies this
development more than scar
a survivor of the ishvalan war of
extinction scar targets state alchemists
out of revenge
to him not only are alchemists weapons
but they transgress
against god who alone possesses the
right to create
but as scar learns more about ermestrus
he realizes how wrong he was to seek
vengeance
who once cloaked his actions in the
words of god finally understands that
no ideology can justify murder scar even
breaks from the strict laws that govern
his faith
making use of the very alchemy that his
god aborts in order
to save the country he once hated
[Music]
him
[Music]
star's transformation stands in stark
contrast to the show's main antagonist
father who clings to his single-minded
belief
in science father becomes obsessed with
the power of alchemy and takes this
obsession to the logical
extreme viewing mankind is little more
than materials for him to use in
becoming god
blinded by scientism father can't
understand the value of human emotions
and discards them in his attempt to
become
perfect he literally rips the seven
deadly sins from himself
lust greed sloth gluttony
envy wrath and pride who in turn become
the other homunculi
ultimately it's this conviction in the
absolute supremacy of science and the
ability to achieve
perfection through it that undoes father
the souls trapped in the philosopher's
stone which he dismissed as
mere energy begin to assert their wills
and rebel against him
father's conception of a soul as a mere
ingredient fails to account for the
autonomy of these individuals
after an epic punch to the gut father is
finally killed and
dragged back into the void from whence
he came where he meets the real god
a being called truth still desperately
clinging to scientism
father demands to know what he did wrong
but unlike scar and others father
refused to recognize
any kind of human wisdom beyond alchemy
[Music]
all of this goes to show what makes ed
and al particularly special throughout
the series
their humble rejection of a single
ideology from the show's outset the two
grapple with what alchemy is
and what it means to be a state
alchemist
it's this questioning that makes the
brothers seem both naive
and likeable at the brothers core is a
strong desire to discover their own
truth
when psychopath extraordinaire sulfshay
kindly has alphonse cornered
he wonders why our hero doesn't just
take the philosopher's stone and get his
body back
sure the country would face certain
destruction from father
but that's just equivalent exchange in
action in order to get their bodies back
they'd have to give up the world's
safety
but al rejects that alchemic world view
reaffirming their desire to find their
own truth
it's this search for possibilities that
distinguishes the brothers and allows ed
to make his final transmutation
after al sacrifices himself in order to
give ed his arm back
ed follows his brother into the portal
to bring him back when asked by the
truth
what price he'll pay ed smiles and
offers his ability to perform alchemy ed
recognizes the arrogance in thinking
that alchemy could explain everything
let alone solve all his problems
[Music]
unlike father who couldn't accept his
place in the universe and equated
alchemy with power
ed knows the truth
[Music]
[Music]
with their bodies back in the day saved
what's left for our heroes to do
in typical elric fashion it's to keep
searching for truth and new methods to
discover it
as alphonse puts it they want to give
back to the people who help them all
along their journey
but it's not a simple give and take not
a cold formula like the law of
equivalent exchange
to that end al is traveling east and ed
west in hopes of gathering
all the knowledge to make this principle
a reality
of course old habits tend to die hard
and when ed
finally confesses his feelings to winry
it comes out like this
[Music]
of course maybe ed didn't need to go so
far from home to realize that science
alone
can't explain everything
we waited 64 episodes for that moment
and it was damn worth it
so what do you think wisecrack will pure
devotion to science lead us down a dark
path
do we need to inject a little i don't
know maybe philosophy into how we look
at the world
let us know what you think in the
comments as always thanks for watching
peace